[موسيقى]
كانت بدايه بحثنا عن الكاكائين من مدينه
كركوك بالعراق هنا رتبنا لقاء مع الناشط
الكاكائي رجب الذي سخر حياته للمطالبه
بحقوق الكاكائيين للحفاظ على ارسهم
التاريخيه الذي صار مهددا بالاندثار
اين رينو باور رينجرز
اله واحد وان هناك الها واحدا
ويعرف ديننا اليوم بدين يرسان في العراق
يطلقون علينا اسم الكاكائين وفي ايران
يسموننا اهل الحق وفي اماكن اخرى مثل
افغانستان والهند وباكستان يطلقون علينا
الخالق اما السبب اطلاق اسم الكاكائين
علينا في العراق
يعتقد اليرسانيون وهو الاسم الثاني الذي
يطلق على الككاكايين ان الالهه تجلى سبع
مرات في هيئه بشر وكانت البدايه مع يار
وهي الجوهر الالهيه ثم جاء بعدها خوان كار
ثم جاء بعدهما الامام علي وكان هذا سببا
لربطهم بالشيعه او الالهيه العلويه خصوصا
بعد ان قام معلمان وهما اب وابنه من هذه
الطائفه
والملقبان بنعمه الله جيهون وابنه نور علي
بتاليف كتاب شهير تحت عنوان برهان الحق
الصادر من طهران حيث كان الكتاب تقربا من
الشيعه بهدف الحمايه الطائفيه
[موسيقى]
تفضل اسمعكم ذلك عن قصده هذه هي معاناتنا
من يسمع ذلك يقول اصبحتم شيعه هذه هي
مشكلتنا لن نسم الامام علي يتردد كثيرا في
طقوس المناجاه والشعائر لذلك فن الطهمه
الموجهه لنا باننا اصبحنا شيعه تاتي من
ذلك لذلك من السهوله ان يتم اتهامنا
بالتشيع ومن يسمع شعائرنا وتقوسها مناجاه
يتكون لديه راي باننا الشيعه ولا يصدق غير
ذلك
وبعض القوه السياسيه تعمل على توكيد ذلك
خطوه بخطوه
متاكده ان اي كاكائيا لم ولن يصبح شيعيا
في يوم من الايام ولكن بعضهم يقول انا
شيعي للدفاع عن نفسه وضمان سلامته ولتحقيق
بعض اهدافه لان الرابطه بين الانسان ودينه
اقوى واهم من بعض المنافع الماديه صحيح هو
يقول امام الناس انه شيعي حمايه